تَجِدُونَا في كُلِّ مَكَانْ
لا لا لا لا
اَشْكَالٌ شَتَّى وأَلْوَانْ
خُضَرٌ طَازِجَةٌ وَشَهِيَّةْ
لا لا لا لا
غِذَاء صِّحي لِلإِنْسَانْ
من بَيْنَ الخُضَرِ أَنَا جَزَر
مَا أَلْطَفَنِي أُقَوِّي النَّظَرَ
لَوْنِي مُبْهِجْ يَا حُلْوِينْ
وأَنَا غَنِيٌّ بِالفِيتَامِينْ
نحن نحن نحن  الخضار
طَازِجَةٌ يُنْعِشُكُمْ طَعْمِي
أَنَا خِيَارٌ أَخْضَر لَوْنِي
أَلْيَافِي نافعة لِلْهَضْمِ
يُحْزِنُنِي لَوْ تَنْسَوا إِسْمِى
نحن نحن نحن  الخضار
أنَا أنَا الطَمَاطِمُ يا أَطفَالْ
أَجْعَلُكُمْ مِثْلَ الأَبْطَالْ
لَوْنِي الأَحْمَرُ مَا أَحْلاَهْ
جَذَّابٌ يَلْمَعُ ما أبهاه
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
فُلْفُلْ فُلْفُلْ أَنَا الفُلْفُلْ
أَحْمَرْ أَخْضَرْ أَيْضًا أَصْفَرْ
مِنِّي حُلْوٌ ومِنِّي حَارْ
أُعْطِى طَبَقَكَ أَبْهَى مَنْظَرْ
نحن نحن نحن  الخضار
بَصَلَة بَصَلَة هَذَا شَكْلِي
موجودة فِي كُلِ الأَكْلِ
أَمْنَحُكُمْ صِحَّةْ وَمَنَاعَةْ
فِي النَفْعِ لاَ يُوُجَدُ مِثْلِي
نحن نحن نحن  الخضار
أَنَا بَطَاطَا لَوْنِي بُنِّي
مَشْهُورَة بِشَكْلِي وَلَوْنِي
بِالنَّشَوِيَّاتِ مُغَذِّيَّةْ
والنَّاسُ جَمِيعًا تَعْشَقُنِي
تَجِدُونَا في كُلِّ مَكَانْ
لا لا لا لا
اَشْكَالٌ شَتَّى وأَلْوَانْ
خُضَرٌ طَازِجَةٌ وَشَهِيَّةْ
لا لا لا لا
غِذَاء صِّحي لِلإِنْسَانْ